hey everybody good morning it is Mike
it's uh
Thursday September 8th it's 10 o'clock
Chicago time and we're gonna get started
here I'm just going through a couple of
last minute checks making sure the sound
is
working making sure my screen is sharing
and hopefully you can see this uh little
robotic guy up there on the screen and
you could hear me okay so
order flows and markers right you know
everybody wants to automate the trading
right it's going to make life easier
because you know trading is one of those
things where there there is downtime
it's a lot of sitting around and you
know sitting on your hands waiting for
the trade signal to come up and
sometimes you know if you get distracted
sometimes you know you're
distracted you know you see something
pop up on on your phone and you go to
look and next thing you know you've
missed the trade and you know automating
a signal using the tools that are
available you know such as markers you
know it's going to make your life easier
right and that's what we all want to do
as Traders is make our lives easier so
today it's going to be you know a pretty
simple straightforward laid-back
presentation on explaining markers what
it does and how to integrate it with the
order flow uh indicators so
brief disclaimer before we get started
what I got up here
you know we're all adults here we all
understand that trading involves risk
and only risk Capital should be used for
trading only those with sufficient risk
Capital should consider trading remember
past performance not necessarily
indicative of Futures results
so like I said trading by ourselves
right in our little office our home
office or you know on our laptop
somewhere
is very lonely right we feel like we're
enslaved to the screen and it has some
side effects to it right and they're
negative side effects your stress levels
rise while the quality of your life
declines basically because you know if
you're an active intraday Trader you you
want to watch what's happening in the
market right unless you know if you're a
macro Trader you don't need to automate
your trading you know you just sit there
you know laid back and okay yeah I think
uh you know I think copper is going to
Rally you know over the next two months
and you know you're not price sensitive
but if you're an active intraday Trader
you want to automate your entries and
by automating your trade entries that
takes off a lot of heavy lifting because
you're not worried about you know
getting in late to a trade you're not
worried about missing a trade you don't
have that emotion of oh you know what I
just had two losers in a row you know
then you get a signal on the third one
and you're like uh you know I just had
two losers in a row do I want to take it
do I want not and you don't take it and
then that's the trade that you get
um you know the nice winner on so
nowadays it's quite amazing what trading
software can do to help facilitate your
trading and you know I've been working
doing these presentations with Pablo
because for years now because you know
ever since
gosh I don't know you know the old
versions of ninjatrader el Pablo had
this tool called markers
and basically it made trading a lot
easier right you can automate
all of your trading or you could
automate part of it you know when I
first started using markers it was just
to
take the trades when they appeared right
now when it comes to automating order
flow you need to be able to identify
trade setups that is why I went from
the order flow chart itself into
creating indicators which are my trade
setups because a computer you know the
software needs a reason to buy or sell
all you're doing is you're telling the
computer this is the parameters get in
now period so you know for example right
Delta increasing by a certain percentage
over X number of bars
you need to give the computer something
tangible
trade-off of
and that's why you know over the years
I've created Delta based indicators the
way I look at Delta imbalance based
indicators the ways that I look at
imbalance and the order flow value-based
indicators now the way I analyze value
obviously there's order flow volume
based indicators structure based
indicators and much more now soon right
the
have been talking about this with my
regular users the actual footprint that
we have the actual order flows Trader 5
software we are working on a version
that can be read by tools like markers
right markers is sort of our Benchmark
that you know if we know that if it
could run on markers that we're good to
go so you're going to be able to
automate things like you know Delta
divergences prominent points of controls
you know exhaustion prints things like
that that are already pre-built into the
order flows Trader footprint chart
now
when you look at an order flow footprint
chart right like currently right now
you have to decide you know what it is
that's causing you to get into a trade
right is you know if you're analyzing
Delta now
get analyze point of control it could
analyze imbalances there's so many
different ways to analyze order flow but
at the end of the day when you're
trading right if you want to automate it
you need to sort of indicatorize your
analysis your form of analysis
and that's why I've created tools over
the years you know things like Delta
scalper right which
tell you where to buy where to sell
that makes reading this footprint chart
a lot easier right then once you've
taken away the the level or the layer
rather of trade entry right because now
you you have your parameters set up that
you can plug into markers to take trades
then that leaves you
more what do you want to call it
emotional Capital psychological Capital
to manage the trade reading the order
flow so once you get into the trade then
you could be
a Trader
right because being a Trader is making
those decisions you know do I let the
trade run do I cut Pro no I cut losses
do I take profits early you know if the
market gets up to a level and doesn't
quite hit it you know what am I going to
do or if I'm scaling you know if I've
got a multiple position on and I get out
of one you know but I've got a runner up
here you know how to move my stop up to
break even or or move it up to take you
know a small profit things like that
right that that is a lot of work for a
Trader to do
but now by automating your signals your
trade entry you're freeing up your brain
so to speak to
concentrate more once you're in the
trade
now
Pablo right he has a tool it's called
markers plus and you know again it's
some of you I know already have it and
because I've got a lot of comments from
people over the last couple months hey
when you guys going to do another
presentation together
and you know your your emails even
though
um yeah I couldn't give you a specific
time and date you know I have been
answered and you know that's why I'm
happy to bring Pablo in today
to discuss you know markers because what
I'm going to talk about
is using not just
the order flow indicator itself like
Delta scalper but how to actually filter
out trades using markers
and to confirm what I'm seeing in there
and take the trade so I'll get into it
you know when it's my turn to speak but
for now I'm going to turn it over to uh
the Pablo here so just give me a second
and I'll let Pablo go for a little while
and talk about what he wants to talk
about because you know what every time
Pablo sends me an email with the video I
learned something new you know he sent
me a video the other day to watch and I
was like you know what gosh I kicked
myself for not uh using markers this way
earlier so anyway I'll turn it over to
Pablo here
um and let him
let him speak hey Pablo should have
control
hello everyone and thank you Mike
okay let me discover what I need to
click and
this one
okay can you see my my chart
yes okay
okay
um
currently markers is
a lot more than certain automation tool
you can create your R1 signals and even
more now that Mike was commenting me
that the the his new indicator is going
to show more uh data from the from the
order flow so you can create your own
logic but more about that later because
for those who have no idea what is
markers okay markers is
everything that is inside this folder
indicator store not everything from here
to here
the most important tools are markers
copy
with microscopy we just assign a name of
a variable to any of the lines or plots
that you have on the chart for example
this is the order flow flow shift this
indicator has
two plots by signal cell signal usually
they have none available when they are
not printed and now it has a value that
value
3970.50 is the price where this triangle
is printed okay I I don't care where it
is printed I I am only interested in
that it is printed okay we have a signal
so we can copy this indicator and do
something with this usually we just copy
and execute okay
this is the most the simplest solution
but we can do a lot more of that for
example if we execute all those signals
this short is against the trend
and today we were commenting uh I I even
uploaded a video this week explaining
how to do this so I am not going to be
to to go into too much detail because
there's a big video about that but you
can for example use a slope of this line
this line is an HMA but it can be
anything okay you can use the slope of
this line to decide the flow is to the
upside take only longs so this short is
avoided the slope is to the downside
take this short and we can we can go
this for example this is in the middle
of nowhere
so we can say the the slope we can we
can take the magnitude of the flow if
the slope is almost horizontal it is no
bigger than something no less than
something we do nothing or we can
execute this is our decision
here for example the same
this one the slope is to the upside we
can take this long or here the slope is
to the upside why
should I take this short
even so the short is a win array because
we can we can get
um a Target but the idea is we can add
more to this and not only not only that
we can also Define our pattern for
example maybe I want to enter on a green
bar after the Red Bar
and this is just a very simple logic
that we can add
um
to to avoid making this a more
more long uh let me show you something
that I was commenting with with Mike and
you know that most of the order flow
indicators need tick replay and you go
to data series
and you need click replay
because
to calculate the the parameters needed
for overflow for each one we need tick
by tick inside this bar and the the
usual data for a minute bar are only
four and they open they close the high
and low but this is not enough to
calculate another flow indicator we need
all the ticks and also at which time
which part of the bar they they are uh
calculated so this takes a lot of time
and you you can you can
notice this when you reload Niche script
that it takes some time to calculate all
of this all right
and even more it is still calculating
even more if you have more than one and
this is where we may have a problem
depending on the number of charts and
the the power of your computer
um most of the order flow indicators out
there
force you to use tick replay so if you
don't enable tick replace now the
references finishes if you don't enable
quick replay the result of indicator is
a message that indicates that you need
to enable the replay
but on Max indicators that's not true
because you can turn off something like
this
turn off the replay
and all the historical is not calculated
it is loading now okay now we don't have
to replay
that means that for the historical
we are not doing an analysis each bar is
calculated by the four basic points open
high low and close so it is quick and
fast so if you are trading live this is
important I I want to change the the
period of this line I can double click I
can make it faster
and I don't need to wait all the
calculation again hey so it is fast and
I know that from the moment I do a
refresh real time everything is
calculated stick by tick so the mic
indicators are going to work and the
signals are going to be printed
even more you can say okay how can I get
I am not interested in looking at three
days ago I I am only interested in
two-day signals and I don't want to use
a pick replay
uh maybe we go because I want to copy
the signals
and an example let's say I want to
copy the signals of this indicator the
order flow flow shift okay and I need to
use the same parameters okay so I go to
let me take a screen capture of this
so
I don't mess with the parameters
and now when I go to copy microscopy
let me let me decrease the size of this
so I can see the parameters
now I am going to copy the the two plots
of the indicator
Marcus copy
and for the name go along
and I want to copy a fast signal okay
because I I'm only interested in detect
and execute no more than that
um
inside input series I need to place the
indicator I am going to copy the
indicator is this one or any indicator
that you want to automate
this
and I need to set all the parameters
exactly as the one I have on the chart
and I guess they are all the same yes
they are all the same I need to select
also the plot
I want to copy the long
okay
and also important the indicator I I
want to copy how it works it works
at each tick so I need to copy in the
same way so I copy
on each stick
when I click on OK
it is fast and nothing is printed
because it is not taking the time needed
to calculate because I I don't have tick
replay enabled
uh this is something important because
if you are if you have the original
indicator and then you have the copy of
the lungs and you have the copy of the
shorts then you are calculating the
logic of the indicator three times one
for the original one for the Longs
another for the short so it is taking
three times The Standard Time
and that may be a lot so not using tick
replay is okay for trading live if you
want to do a quick change the problem is
how can I know that it is doing what I
want and here is a quick tip if if you
are Maybe
if you don't have too much time you can
disconnect
to playback
and go to now go to today
so let's go to you can click on go to
now
today and
my local time is uh
what time it is
in my computer
[Music]
um
12 20.
p.m no or yeah
and this is today
yes today okay
so the this is what we had previously
again click replay is a off not the
replay so when I reload Nisha Grid or
when I click here nothing is calculated
but on playback we have an option
that instead of playback from the
selected time we can play back from the
start of the day here
what's the difference that I can click
on go to don't change nothing
so the the same time the time is the
same but I click on OK so all the day is
a playback real time tick white dick
you get the signals because this is what
happens real time real time everything
is calculated tick by tick
now let me see if we can see the copies
because where I have a
here
I am not sure if you can see but let me
magnify this
here
can you see the triangle is from Mike's
indicator this little Dot
is the copy so this is a way we have to
verify that what I copy is what I get
and I can select
right click
copy
unselect clicking anywhere right click
on paste
so now I have two copies
two copies
copying exactly the same so they are
overlapping
two both are the same now we can convert
the second copy to the short
go short and they copied indicator is
the same with all the same parameters so
I need to I don't need to check one by
one because it is a copy I only need to
change the signal
okay
and just to make it different we can
change the color make it red
we can make it bigger so we can see it
more easily and the same for the lungs
and again when I click on OK everything
is gone
so I don't have a way to
um
to verify what are we doing but no
problem because we can right click
go to a with this option selected and
Playback the current day go to
okay
and then we have a playback here we can
see that we get the signals and also the
dots so that means that what we copy is
what we want
no problem
and
using this method you don't need to have
thick replay enable you can verify
quickly that your setup is working
turn off playback
go to live of course the historical
signals are removal but you are sure
that what you get is what you want okay
on that video I I was mentioning before
I am going to share with you the the
link I also explain how to add more
logic because maybe I don't want to
execute all the signals as they are
maybe I want to add a filter or maybe I
want to detect ever pattern if our
pattern could be for example
the signal happens on
two red bars after a green bar how can I
detect two red bars after a green bar
with just the Marcus logic
I I I let me know Mike if I am going too
far I don't want to use not for much of
your time okay that's fine so
let's say that we want to detect this
bar pattern green red
so you can add that word pattern to your
signals so first they take the bar
pattern with a logic
we can say that the current barrier
sorry the current the current bar is red
so the close is below the open
but the previous bar was also red
so the close one Vargo is also below the
open
but at the beginning of the power
pattern I have a green bar
they close
was greater than the open
with only this logic I am detecting our
pattern I I am not taking into account
if if this is a flow shift signal or not
so let's paint a signal in red
and just that
now the logic is going to calculate when
I have a green red red green red red
green red red and then I can use this as
a filter
on markers for the original signals
example
when I have markers
this is a beta sorry the last available
release is 2021 I am just about to
release the version for this year but
this is with a in beta version
okay
um fast signal mode trading go long and
go short and I can add a filter
here
what is a filter ah here
where I can type exactly the same
formula or I can type the result of this
formula in my opinion it is easier to
just
copy all these
this this should be the filter for a
short so I can copy
and
paste on on the short side no
this is one of the options another
option is to
make this logic to create a variable
for example
filters
okay
so this is a result of my filter this
histogram and now I can use these
filters
this
copy
and place it on my filter so it is
simpler
shot that okay
so when this is true I am
executing the signals when it is not
true it is doing nothing
the the result needs to be Market needs
to be playing so we can get the the
result of the filter
okay I I need I I need to do a Reload
because I am at the end of the
of my playwork
I I selected as end time the end of my
playback so I I cannot click on a play
after that because this is the end of my
data stream
okay here we are
and shorts are disabled
because the condition is not true if we
were here for example here
shorts should be enabled okay this is an
example and this is working as you as
you can see it now the only problem is
we get all the signals printed although
all of them are printed but marker is
deciding is is filtering filtering the
signals or not
uh this is useful if you want to have
the option to turn on or off the filter
but if you want to filter always always
signals then you can set everything
inside the logic for example
now if I want to
paint
these signals when I also have
um
a short flow shift signal then I can
show in
one and the other
so on the copies
instead of instead of doing a copy
as a fast signal I need to copy as a
variable because I I need to calculate
something else
so I copy no longer FIFA signal
and the value of those variables are the
price where the signal is printed
and now on the logic I can say
and also
go short
on the current bar is not equal to zero
or greater than zero
I I don't need the filter now in this
version
and when this is true
creative a signal go short
so now the first signal is created by
the logic and the logic is looking at
the result of mic indicators and also
your
bar pattern or whatever your filter
again if I click on OK
nothing is going to be true because I
don't have the replay enabled
you can enable tick replay but take into
account the time it is going to take
and also something important let me show
you
that time
that the indicator
takes to calculate maybe bigger than 5
Seconds okay all markers indicators have
a timeout
so if the time to calculate is bigger
than uh five DC five seconds five
thousand milliseconds if it takes more
than five seconds the result is false so
nothing is printed if you need to
increase the time you can make I don't
know 100 seconds
is 100
000 milliseconds okay
the the only problem is if you make a
mistake on one of these variables it is
going to wait those 100 seconds to shut
showing variable Note phone okay
anyway using this method we are not
using tick replay it is not taking
nothing to calculate this because we are
working real time
now let's see if it is working real time
okay go to
okay
this one here we have a flow shift
signal
and it looks like the the only one
this is the only low shift short signal
where I also have a wire pattern
not this one
no because this is not red
this is a Doshi
and this is the
top of the iceberg because you can do a
lot of things with this
um
I I don't know if there is any question
or you might you have any any other
question about this yeah I got a
question
um so for like if you're using the logic
right you just created that one for
short so for Longs you'd have to add
another one for Longs is that correct
yes for example are the easiest way the
easiest way is copy and paste because
the logic is very simple so I I have a
signal here so you can select
right click
copy
click anywhere
right click on paste now I have two
signals the second one is not printed
because it is calculated historical but
anyway it is going to work and now I
just replace the logic
on the second logic this one
instead of how short it is go long the
name of the first signal instead of
painting in red we can paint in Blue
uh the logic is
that your signal
go long
ER than zero
it exists leave better than zero means
that it exists and also the bar pattern
is in the other direction so the current
bar is a green the previous bar is also
green and
this the the beginning is less
and that's all no yes yes it is that's
all
okay
and he said this version right now is in
beta right so no no no no what I am
showing now it is it is present from
yeah but your version that you're
running is still but this is available
on the current version but yeah yeah I
am not showing new features right right
right okay
okay
um yeah guys so you know that
that was pretty cool
you know it's it's like like Pablo said
you know it's just the tip of the
iceberg of
you know the analysis that you can add
to
you know one of my indicators or any
other indicator that you're using and
you know just sort of to go back to what
he was talking about the tick replay
right you know that like my
yeah in ninjatrader 7 to ninjatrader 8
the big shift was in the way ninjatrader
handles data sort of you know on the
back end you know the things ways that
we don't see and tick data was the way
to get
the historical data for you know order
flow plotted correctly because you know
the problem with ninjatrader 7 every
time you load a chart you know with an
order flow based indicator you'd
sometimes get different signals but
allowing you to do back testing you know
with the order flow based indicator you
know you would use tick replay but if
you're trading in real time
the way that my indicators work is you
actually don't need that tick replay
because sometimes people say oh yeah
I'll take replay slows down their
machine sometimes you know people have
older processors or things like that and
you know running tick replay you know
especially on markets like NASDAQ if
you're trying to load a chart there's so
much data it can take time but if you
want to you know if you're trading in
real time you don't need to have tick
replay enabled on your chart you know
that my uh software my indicators will
read the data that's coming in correctly
and plot you know starting from the time
you open up your chart so you know I
sort of forgot about that until Pablo
reminded me because to be honest you
know I'm so used to using tick replay
because you know for myself sometimes I
get a little sidetracked you know during
the day I want to open up another chart
and you know look at something and say
you know nowadays the markets aren't
that quiet but you know say I want to
look at
um you know a British pound chart and a
I was so used to using tick replay to
look at you know has there been movement
you know has there been anything
interesting in the order flow that day
but as far as trading in in real time
you don't need to have tick replay
enabled so that was a um a nice reminder
a sort of honestly I sort of forgot
about that but uh Pablo I'm going to
take the screen back okay okay
all right guys so you know Pablo talked
about a couple things you know the tech
bar patterns and you know for example
the green bar followed by two red bars
honestly I didn't realize how strong
that was just looking at the chart you
know I saw a lot of signals on on that
so you imagine you could add you know
bar patterns as as a filter you could
um you know do crossovers between two
indicators you know maybe you know say
you want to this moving average and that
moving average along with you know order
flow or you know V web say you know
we're trading above you'll see the
this V web process that you know today's
V web process yesterday's V web and you
know you're looking for traits in that
direction
um or use the slope of the line as a
filter for Longs and shorts and you know
basically what that means is you know
when don't don't get think you're going
to be doing you know geometry or
anything oh I gotta figure out the slope
of the line now basically if say you
have a you know an average like a moving
average or you know HMA the whole moving
average which is is a nice one to use
um you know you're only going to take
shorts in the direction that price is
moving so you know if or rather the the
the HMA is moving so say you will only
want to take shorts if it's moving down
and take Longs if it's moving up so you
can do that right so you can add
filters
to the order flow signal right and you
know that can filter out trades that you
know you probably don't want to be taken
you'll say we're in a sideways Market we
all know that if the market is going
sideways trying to take trades you're
going to get chopped up
you want to be taking trades you know
going in the direction of the market
movement you know I I love to try and
you know find these turning points in
the market but oftentimes they come
after a move down and a move starts
going up but after a move starts going
up you have a trend oftentimes it can go
sideways and you don't have that
movement down and sometimes you could be
sitting in a consolidation period for a
while and not even knowing it until you
know afterwards and you're taking trade
after trade and getting stopped out
so
when you're trading automated right for
me there's two types right there's fully
automated you know trade entry trade
exit partially automated trade entry and
you manage the trade right and decide
where to get out now
trading right even automated trading
yeah it's a job and you got to treat it
like that you got to realize there's
work that you have to do right now you
won't be glued to your screen but that
doesn't mean that you know
there's no work for you to do right you
still got to you know run your tasks and
and see you know what works for you you
know your risk level things like that
um what kind of Trader you are like for
me okay I prefer
I'm a Hands-On guy right I read the
order flow and I use a tool
markers to help me with the trade entry
because sometimes you know especially
you know if if I'm talking to somebody
and I'm Trading something's happening in
one market I'm not necessarily paying
attention to if you could automate that
it gives you that extra advantage of
still being in the trade rather than
missing it you know when I used to have
my live trading room years ago you know
everyone wants to be entertained so you
find yourself talking all the time and
I'll be talking about British pound and
I'm missing the move in the the mini Dow
you know it's just unfortunate like that
but having a tool like markers if I look
away from the screen
at least I'm in the trade when it
happens so
after I'm in the trade you know then
it's got my attention then I can start
watching you know do I stay in the trade
do I
you know cut my loss or you know do I
let this is is the order flow very
bullish if I belong do I stay in longer
and
you know having
a tool to get you into trade is half the
battle right they say in life you know
90 of life is just showing up and the
same thing is is
in trading yeah let's say at least half
a trading is just taking the trade so
what I'm going to do now is I'm gonna
talk about you know if you go through an
example here with this is the Delta
scalper and the setup is it's very easy
to have it already set up actually I've
got the slides here I mean I could go
through it but it really just takes a
few seconds you know you're just adding
markers I'll have all this you know when
I when I send out the replay I'm gonna
send out the the sheet that goes along
with it so you can see but I'm just
going to put it up here and you know
just in case you know you're watching
the the screen you can just screenshot
all this now
when it gets to the indicator right I
have it highlighted here so when I say
flow shifts you know if you're using
flow shifts like
Pablo was using or using Delta scalper
you can't you know you just choose the
indicator okay so it's interchangeable
it doesn't matter if you're using you
know Delta scalper or or turns or price
rejector
um you know or any of the other
indicators you just
choose that one instead of choosing the
one that's highlighted here
okay and you know with markers copy you
got to set one up for the buy one up for
the cell and when it gets to adding the
filter
okay I'm what I'm using is you know a
long filter and a short filter based off
of the HMA the whole moving average
and the important thing to keep in mind
is you have to
have sort of that equation right the
filter of the bar before is is greater
or say the current bar is greater than
the bar before at and
for the opposite for shorts is this
right so but again I'm going to send you
this so that you have a copy of it okay
because
it's one thing to watch it I mean I
could go through it but you know it
would take some time but I've got it all
set up here you know ready to go now you
know some of the important things to
remember
is you know when you're
first starting out using
markers
you think
it gives you a chance to play around
with you know sort of your different
ATMs that you want to use for the market
that you're trading so for example right
I have this one this is a three lots
because this is s p so this is three
lots the first Target is 16
um ticks stop loss at eight and that's
for two contracts the second target is
you know a little bit more of a runner
stop loss is still the same the target
though this time is 24.
and so it's two and one right total of
three now again you don't have to you
could use you could set up whatever you
want right say I you know I could have
just one contract with a stop loss of a
to take profit of 16 or you know eight
and
twelve or eight and fourteen you know
it's up to you now do keep in mind
with the markets nowadays
the night session obviously is much more
quieter than the day session you do get
nice movements in the overnight if
if you're running something like this
you know and
eight lot eight ticks overnight is okay
but during the day you get stopped out
really quick right so you probably want
to have a little bit wider
um stops but at the same time the moves
are a bit bigger during the day so you
could have a wider take profit but again
that's going to come down to your
testing and also depends on the type of
chart that you're using because
you know a one minute chart trades
differently than a four range chart than
an eight range chart or then you know a
100 tick chart
so you know you got to put in that leg
work but trust me you know once you put
in that that leg work it really becomes
worthwhile too so
I'm sure I got this on here
and you know I'll just start running
through it here oh I got my speed this
is just we're starting the roll today so
honestly this is the September contract
I just downloaded the data for the last
two days so you see it gets me into the
trade automatically
right here right it didn't take the
short because this line This HMA is
trending up
right now again you don't have to use an
HMA you could use whatever line you like
you know maybe you want to use you know
there are tools out there for
you know I haven't gotten that far yet
but
um
using a cumulative Delta you know what's
cumulative Delta doing is it going up or
down
um you know or I know some people like
to even
yeah I think there's a point of control
average out there because if you're
looking at a footprint
right you can see you know is cumulative
Delta going up maybe I only want to take
trades if cumulative Delta is rising
relative to the previous ones or
opponent controls are rising you know
that's something that hopefully you know
we'll be rolling out me at order flows
um you know in the near future so
if I'm trading this okay so let me just
turn it back on right I could run it
on the normal bar chart right and then
if I'm just watching my footprint chart
you know the same trades will show up I
could still manage it from this trade
this chart
so like if I see you know something in
the order flow that I don't like and I'm
still in the profit I could cut it or
you know if maybe the market is just
sort of going sideways like it is I
could cut it
take a small profit or you know if
nothing's happened you know just just
let it run right again so
what do I got this is you know this is a
three lot setup
you know it's the stop of two ticks so
you can see now here backed Prof back to
break even I took the loss okay it could
stop me out but if I saw the market was
just going sideways all that time you
know maybe I I would be a bit interested
in cutting the trade
right so this you know I like to manage
it you know I don't like to have things
set and forget that's just me so like
yeah here I've seen oh it just keeps
hitting you know coming within a tick of
my my Target and it's not quite getting
it you know I could sit there say you
know what I want to do do I want to
adjust the limit or not so like in this
case here
okay I got filled on two
I've still got one lot on as a runner
that the take profit right is down at
the bottom here
right but we're just sort of hanging
around here right I still have a stop up
here this is my entry
you know after a certain amount of time
I could decide you know do I still want
to be in it or you know I'm not getting
paid you know what am I going to do do I
do I cut it uh here it cut it
automatically because it had a
another signal
but you know you don't always have those
Opera you know those chances to take
that so you can see at this point
so far today you know it's okay it's 87
dollars
let me speed things up here
but again you know that that's the
beauty of it is you know you can still
use whoops you can still use your order
flow chart
and
you know take the trade so
let the computer take the trades for you
and you just manage it right so it's
like
you know here I got some stop outs right
I mean again this is two in the morning
so
you know it is what it is at this time
so I mean you know right now I'm under
water 150 bucks so far
and you know okay but you know trading
is not one trade it's not a Sprint it's
it's a marathon
but I know that I have you know my my
stop is eight ticks my first take profit
is double that so it's two to one
and I even got that other Runner which
is four to one but the beauty is you
know I could
let the I could let the runner I could
cut it shorter or I could even let it
run further it's a bit of
honestly a free trade but it's something
that you can work with so I mean you can
see you know at this point it's you know
what three in the morning
this is I forgot what day this was on
the 5th or the 6th rather
it's on the six at three in the morning
you know it
I I mean this is I don't I don't want
you thinking that this is what it's like
every single morning but it's you know
it's up fifteen hundred dollars on on
trading three contracts with that
parameter
um you know I do have other
stops
um ATMs rather you know eight tick with
14 tick take profit
and you know it's also
pretty consistent so you can see you
know right now time is it four in the
morning you know I just
had it you know I got stopped out down
at the bottom here
you know I'm sort of running this a bit
fast but you know again I want you to
sort of see the what you can do right so
I'm in this position finally it went up
there
went for the take profit
but again this is with Delta scalper
right there's a lot of other you know
indicators that I have that run with
markers okay and again you know the
setup is is pretty simple right I I
showed you that template on the slides
and I'll send that out you know later
and when I post the replay up you know
I'll have it in the description of the
video so that you can
take advantage of it but you see
nothing's happening right here
okay so right now there's there's no
trades but it's only taking Longs if
this line is sloping up and taking
shorts if the the line is you know
sloping down
okay so it hit the first Target right so
this is interesting right
it hit the first targets
right here my entry is 47 right I got my
buy stop up here at 49. this is what I
talk about you know being able to manage
the trade
if it's just hanging around here
all right it made a run towards my take
profit didn't quite my target on you
know the other the runner trade
didn't quite hit it right it got within
a half a point 41 and a half it's down
here at 41 and then just sort of hanging
around here
I don't need to leave this stop up at
you know at 49 you know I could move it
down to the break-even level right that
that's the beauty of
you know automation gets you in the
trade but then you can still trade you
know do your job as a Trader and you
know just and let it go right so you
know at worst case you just break even
on that on that one contract
so there you know it went up it stopped
me out but I broke even right I didn't
take a loss because we didn't hit my
take profit could have been
yeah
so you're saying right it's similar
there right it didn't
um
it just just stopped me out there
you know that's one of the things as
traders that discourage Traders a lot is
you know a trade is in your favor and
then it turns around and stops you out
when you know potentially you could have
um
gotten out at a much more desirable
price
so here we're coming into the day
session
you know this is what the p l is running
so far for the day
but again it's just three lots on the
bigs or not bigs but three lots on the
the e-minis you know the the normal
contract
there's the cash open so just reversed
right back up
see that's what I'm talking about right
during the cash once the cash Market
opens you're
the volatility in the bar picks up so
you know if you're using a tight stop
of you know for the overnight session
when you get into the day session due to
the volatility picking up you could
probably get stopped out
more often
so you may want to adjust that what if
you're trading night session into the
day
you know adjust your stop out to
take that into account
so you can see right it's even though I
got a long signal here it's not taking
that long
because the line is sloping down right
this long here it didn't take the line
is sloping down these shorts it didn't
take one two three because the line is
sloping up
but again you know like Pablo said
that's just the tip of the iceberg
right there's you know Pablo was showing
you how to set it up using bar patterns
right so you know if you only want to
take
you know Longs after a certain you know
bar pattern you know red green green or
green red red you could add that further
filter and of course you know test it
out thoroughly before you
um you know turn it loose
but you know that that's the beauty of
it okay so you know again you know
whether using the stratum
um Delta scalper
you know flow bounce
all these indicators right you could add
you know extra filters in there to
help refine your trading you know and
you know that's why we we got together
today is because you know I know some
people were just using this
using markers just as a way to
enter the trade based on the
based on the signal
right but I'm so I want to do this to
show you you know take it a little step
further and I know some of you guys are
already doing it but for those that
aren't you know hopefully you guys can
um you know have picked something up
here so anyway guys
I'll just stop this for now you know
what time you know it's like 10 in the
morning you know that's the profit
whatever but
um
again I don't want to run too late
on this here but yes Deborah asks does
this work on your new stratum indicator
it does it does and
again Deborah I'm gonna post this this
is
the
flow shifts setup right on how I have it
here right I ran through the slides I'm
going to post it here but all you'd have
to do wherever it says flow shifts on
here you just use the the stratum on
there but again I don't want to go on
too long because it's already almost 11
o'clock
um I will create a separate video and
send it out when I send out the replay
just to
show you the setup on it as well but it
honestly it's really very very
simple I mean all you really have to do
uh screw it you know I still that it
doesn't take that long so you know I'll
do it
really quick here so I'm not going to
use the tick replay
in this instance
out
I got nothing loaded on here so
all I'm going to do is
okay so gotta add stratum
and you know for this example
I'll use this is the settings I'm going
to use okay so just uh magnitude level
of one
I'm going to turn off
that's it just one this one doesn't have
that many settings now all I gotta do is
add on markers copy markers copy
um
markers the force if you want to add an
HMA you can
take you through that again I don't like
this Golden Rod color I think that's an
ugly color so I'll change that and I'll
have to add on another
copy here
this one's going to be for the HMA so
and you know really simple so first one
right this is going to be for my long
signal for stratum Longs I'll call it
enable fast signal go in here enable
in find the indicator
stratum
same settings you know just one this is
the Buy Signal so I'll leave that there
now
how you want it to plot you know I like
to keep it the same Pablo was showing
you how to use the dot if you want to
copy
things
but just uh just keep it simple here
I'll keep it blue triangle up you know
eighth I think is what I use
now for this
for the cells it's really quick
so I'm going to change the marker's name
variable to shorts because it's the cell
again you could have whatever variable
name you want say you know stratum
shorts
can pass signal now go back in here now
I gotta enable the cells
short trades
um turn that off change the plot down
here at the bottom from Buy Signal to
sell signal click ok
and go on each tick
and I'll change this from Blue to red
triangle
down
yeah let's keep it the same I like to
keep the same and I'll go into markers
the force
well these you'll change if you could
change from in here so let's make it
auto and I'll enable fast signals here
okay for now I'll enable Longs and
shorts and so my fast signal lame was
Longs best signal name it was shorts
Longs and Longs okay
um 500
Max profit Max loss on change to five
thousand these are e-minis if you're on
micros you know 500 is probably okay
and you know basically that's it then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
enable the filter in here
okay I'll come back to this in a second
so this is my HMA but I'm not using a 14
I'm using a 50 period
okay so I'm going to go in here to copy
and do
here's the input series to
HMA
okay that's Mama
I don't have my glasses here change that
back to 50.
okay
and again I just like to keep it the
same Navy
and the line
and I could keep that on a bar close let
me just make sure here to do
see on here on the filters so
make sure you add the filter right
that's going back into this part in here
so we're going to add the filter
conditions in here I have pulled that up
because I need to copy that this is the
important thing here
so condition one for longs
right it's going to be there
click ok
condition two for the shorts
and get my page back
in here
control we just copy it in there
okay so make sure that's ticked there
and that's it
so see that took all of about three
minutes to do
um
let me see here's some other questions
uh can you send out a video on how to
stack signals two or three signals with
X number of bars
okay
um
where are we here
yeah manually you ask it's uh
he asked
Will the Market software work with the
order flows Trader software where none
of the indicators drawn on the chart you
know that is something that we're
working on for the new version of order
flows Trader
make these things
right there's a lot of stuff in here on
the overflows Trader the footprint chart
we are
making all these things like the tail
buying and selling tails
Delta Divergence exhaustion prints and
balance reversals
um you know
Market weakness Market sweeps
sequencing Etc we are working on a
version of order flows Trader to make
all of this readable in markers
uh let's see this other question here
so a couple more questions bear with me
here trying to open up the box
I never asked you know is
you had to use it daily yeah it's one of
these things you know what is the best
indicator well there's different
indicators out there right some read
Delta some read point of control you
know and different markers uh I'll show
you different
markets
certain indicators work better on it's
kind of a long question here how many
charts can be traded simultaneously
um
you know it's it's up to you you know
but I do find that
obviously you gotta make sure you have a
good computer you know some reason you
know people's sometimes their their
computers are a bit old
um
you know and they got a lot of other
things running on it I you know for me I
just use a trading PC where it's just
the trading stuff but still some people
you know they like to visit Facebook on
their trading computer and stuff and the
next thing they know is it's got all
these things but
you know for me I I think you can
get away
with at least
in my experience probably five ten
different markets you don't want to
overwhelm yourself because
next thing you know you're going to have
trades going off left and right and you
know you still want to be able to manage
it it's one of those things where you
know everyone thinks about automated
trading is so fantastic you know it's
the way of the future but at the same
time
you know it does require some
babysitting
so just bear that in mind
um
can I do limit price yeah there's
different ways to enter
you know I'm sure that would be a whole
nother video
um
and you know can markers be used with
all indicators yeah I mean you could set
it up with
all these other indicators you know that
well not all of them but you know most
of these other indicators that are
available in
ninjatrader
you know we could just reach out to
Pablo for that
uh
is the stratum indicator like the
markers plus no it's it's an indicator
markers plus reads the
indicator output and and takes the
trades
I'm interested in your order flow turn
pulse package if I want to take just
them which do you prefer well Paulson
turns pulse
raised momentum in the market turns
reads for support and resistance so you
know they're complementary tools
this work with order flows Trader again
I sort of covered that on on the next
version of order flows Trader
uh
I'm not sure
what you're referring to is that I
signed up for your offer from the past
webinar but not received the link to
follow through please help
I'm not sure if you sent it to me or
send it to Pablo but please resend
and yeah guys so anyway
that's all you know does order flow five
those last question is order flow five
have
all your indicators those are available
individual so the individual indicators
read different things that's
not available on the order photos Trader
fives I mean the only
it it what the indicator does right is
it it does performs the analysis that
normally I would do using what I'm
seeing on this chart here you know based
off of
what I'm seeing you know signals
in here like
you know based on the value area or you
know how I would read the Delta things
like that you know so with an individual
indicator does is it it reads the order
flow for you as opposed to the footprint
chart which just
presents the order flow for you now we
do have some tools that you know can
make it easier like this here is very
bullish point of control
okay so you know on a new version you
know when it's available no promises
that it's going to come out this month
but it will signal you know this is for
me this is like an automated almost an
automatic trade if things you know if
the follow through order flow works so
you know being able to trade a signal
like this here is something that I want
to do
and that's what the new version is going
to do so you know the the individual
indicators are based on things that
aren't necessarily visible
or I'll say visible but don't show you'd
have to do the analysis yourself on the
footprint chart
to get those signals basically is what
I'm saying
so anyway guys I in the chat I've put
the link for Pablo's website the
indicator store
and I put a link to my website
orderflows.com you know it's it's these
are tools that as a Trader
you need right I mean don't don't
believe these stories of you know oh
yeah I started with a hundred bucks and
I turned it into ten thousand dollars
trading you know be realistic people you
know unfortunately there is an
investment involved in in trading I mean
obviously you need money for trading and
you know sometimes it bothers me
sometimes because I get messages from
people saying I don't have money to
afford trading software can give it to
me for free well
you know you saw some initiative right
get a job I mean man I mean you
know there's so many job openings now
apparently and I I wish I was a teenager
now I mean you see go work at Target and
get paid like 18 bucks an hour or
something
um you know it's it's I I wish I was
young again but I'm not so anyway guys
thanks for coming out today I said I'll
get the replay out this afternoon and
you know I'll shoot a quick video again
on you know how to sort of take the
steps through setting up markers with
copy and and adding in uh adding in a
filter now
I gotta warn you okay it does take some
effort on your part you may if you're
new to markers it may take you a couple
tries to sort of get the hang of it
right it took me a few tries in the past
to get a hang of it but once I
understood what I was doing you saw how
easy it was for me you know it just took
like a minute just a lot of clicking to
you know add this add that set this set
that it's just you know it's a process
and you know the first time you do it it
will be slow but it's not like that once
you pick it up and and you understand I
mean obviously for Pablo he's a creator
for him it's very easy
but for me it did you know the first
time it it did take some time to make
sure you know I did it correctly and
then obviously you know make sure it's
running correctly and you're doing it
correctly before you turn it loose so
Pablo thanks for taking the time out
today you know I I learned something um
and I've got to get the new version when
it comes out so everybody thanks for
your time and enjoy have a great rest of
the day and enjoy your weekend